Speaker 1: As a general rule, Trump plus India
is a very dangerous combination, likely to
lead to complete and total humiliation.
Trump, when he is alongside Indian Prime Minister
Modi, will often praise extraordinarily authoritarian
ideas.
You might remember that once Donald Trump
spoke in India and mispronounced everything
and the crowd literally started to flee.
You might remember our 2020 video Indian Crowd
Flees as Trump mispronounces everything.
Remember Trump trying to pronounce Indian
names for the army?
Speaker 5: Vijay Come on and Sudarshan Tendulkar.
Speaker 4: You?
Speaker 1: Virat Kohli Yeah.
That was a hell of an event.
Speaker 5: Namaz stay.
Speaker 1: Yes.
Namaz stay.
So anyway, Trump went on Indian TV yesterday.
NDTV New Delhi television and just drops humiliating
whopper after a whopper.
Now I still don't really know why he's appearing
on these shows.
I think that there's probably less interest
lately in having him on what might be more
mainstream American outlets.
That's an interesting question in and of itself.
But Donald Trump appearing alongside the Indian
Prime Minister Modi, and Trump says a lot
of crazy things, including that the United
States is, quote, going to hell.
Speaker 6: But overall, the president and
that's the question that keeps coming up,
that in a democracy, India is considered the
world's largest democracy.
You are the world's oldest.
And that's why we have this relationship.
The democracies function on the principle
that the losing side concedes defeat and the
winning side.
I agree with big silver when you lose in this
case, you haven't.
I mean, in a sense, you still haven't accepted
the outcome of 2020 U.S..
Speaker 5: Because I look at the and take
a look at what happened two weeks ago.
It came out the head of Facebook.
Zuckerberg said the FDA.
Speaker 1: Had a Facebook guys.
Speaker 5: By, came to him and told him this
Russian disinformation, don't say anything.
And they went to the media and they suppressed
it.
That's a major form.
This is a just ballot stuffing.
What they're doing right.
Was so bad and what they're doing.
Speaker 1: See if you can follow his explanation
through the entire clip, I dare.
Speaker 5: You, is a disgrace to our country.
And nobody did anything about it.
And it made they say the pollsters say it
made from a ten to a 20 point difference.
Speaker 1: But can you imagine can you imagine
what he's claiming there?
A 20 point difference because of of of the
Hunter Biden laptop Zuckerberg thing.
So instead of Biden winning by well I don't
even know what was the percentage six Trump
was going to win the popular vote by 14.
I mean it's an absurd claim.
Speaker 6: The election outcome.
Speaker 5: Oh is a tremendous.
They suppressed all of that information probably
illegally.
I assume it was illegally done, but it should
have never done.
Next.
Speaker 6: You you think that this is a kind
of a problematic area when you have an election
outcome?
Absolutely not.
One side doesn't accept.
No, absolutely not.
You know, I mean, we all know there is a lot
of fraud, voter fraud in the United States.
You know, all the Democrat run cities, Democrat
run.
Speaker 1: Districts.
Sorry.
And by the way, if I said earlier that Trump
appeared alongside Modi, this is not Modi.
It's very clearly not Modi.
And I don't know why I had that in my notes,
but this is Shalabh Kumar, the Republican
Hindu coalition founder.
This is not Modi.
I was misinformed and I apologize for that.
Speaker 6: We know that there counties this
time because of the pandemic, it was much
bigger.
It was much bigger.
And that's what essentially happened.
Now, if I you know, first of all, let me also
tell you that Hindu Americans and India in
general, they don't give a hoot about this.
I'm in the community.
I go they travel there every day.
They don't give up things about me.
Feel strongly about it.
Yes.
Yes, he does feel strongly about.
Speaker 1: This now really devolves into just
like a mess of a conversation.
Speaker 5: Things.
You know what?
I feel strongly about our country and our
country is going to hell.
There it.
Speaker 1: Is.
It is going to hell.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Speaker 5: That's what I feel strongly about.
And when you look at what's happened to the
US, when you look at what's happened in two
years to the United States, we've never been
in a position like this ever.
Speaker 6: But you know, some would say, President
Trump, that this this idea of a of a kind
of a stolen or an illegal election can have
consequences in terms of what happened in
January 6th.
Some would say as a consequence of that, that
there was actual violence.
Yeah.
Speaker 5: Well, Democrats have.
Speaker 6: Said it isn't that.
Speaker 5: Democrats have said it for a long
time about different elections.
What is he talking about?
They went out and they said the 2016 election
was stolen.
The same people that now complain and of.
Speaker 1: Course, this is a false equivalency.
The idea that there was an influence campaign
by other countries who preferred Trump over
Hillary Clinton is not the literal theft of
an election in the way that Trump is claiming
there was fraud.
Speaker 5: We're big complainers about 2016.
They say, I stole the election in 2016, which
I didn't do.
But this and.
Speaker 1: By the way, Hillary conceded like
hours after the results.
Speaker 5: Voices that you hear said, no,
no.
There's tremendous proof, this tremendous
evidence.
And again, go back to just two weeks ago when
Zuckerberg said he was told Russian disinformation,
don't say anything.
Don't say anything until after the election.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So there is the I mean, just a bizarre interview.
Here's just one other clip in which Trump
was asked about 2024.
Speaker 6: We just asked you to see both of
you back together again.
Is this all an indication that you are now
set on the road to 2024?
Speaker 5: Well, I mean, momentum.
Everyone wants me to run.
I'm leading in the polls and every poll, the
Republican polls and in Democrat polls.
Speaker 1: And now that's obviously not true.
Earlier I told you about a new poll in which
Joe Biden is leading by six in the hypothetical
matchup, but reality does not matter.
Speaker 5: I'll make a decision in the very
near future, I suspect.
And I think that a lot of people are going
to be very happy.
But we've been friends for a long time.
We've been friends from before the last campaign
in 2016 and then 2020.
And I've had a great relationship to India
and to Prime Minister Modi, where we've been
friends and I think he's a great guy and doing
a terrific job.
It's not an easy job he's got.
So but we've known each other a long time.
Good man.
Speaker 6: Right.
That's an interesting thing.
You said that you said you had to make up
your mind, but a lot of people will be happy
with the decision.
Speaker 5: I think so.
A lot of people will be and a couple of people
will be unhappy.
Speaker 6: Okay.
This is quite an interesting hint that we've
got this.
Why do you think it's now almost a done deal
that President Trump is going to run again
and should he run again?
Is he is he the obvious choice?
Of course he should run again.
That's our view.
And then, you know, it'll be great if he runs
again.
I mean, our community, they will just love
to have.
Speaker 1: Yeah, the Indian community will
just absolutely love Trump and the Hindu community
will love Trump, by the way.
Two communities that don't particularly love
Trump.
But that's the claim that's being made.
What a wild interview.
Truly bizarre stuff.
And again, this this, you know, the right
used to claim very loudly.
No matter what ever happens in the United
States, you never say America isn't great.
You never say America is downhill or going
bad or whatever.
And now it's completely acceptable among these
folks to say, no, no, no, America sucks.
Now you need me to fix it and make it good.
America's going to hell in the Bush era.
Republicans would say, you never say that.
Very, very different Republican Party at this
point
in time.